well imagine uh our weekend without wind
if you can
i'm afraid that's not gonna happen we've
got winds that are coming back tomorrow
beautiful blue skies
and it is cold for your friday lots of
30s out there
mid 30s nellis we've got 39 at the lakes
38 centennial hills
and if you've been sneezing it's likely
you're allergic to ash or elm trees
which
have high pollen counts right now
february
is a time that we do see those trees
busting open
especially when we get some warmer temps
which we'll get at least for a couple of
days next week
this system has opened up it's bringing
a little snow into the intermountain
west it's what's bringing snow to lake
tahoe today
and tonight and it will also bring a
cold front our way as we get into our
saturday
and more wind tomorrow so enjoy the
light winds 63 degrees for the afternoon
high today
up on the mountain look for 48 mostly
sunny skies
and some southwest breezes and then
tomorrow the strong northwest winds will
be up to about
30 miles an hour slightly cooler on
sunday look at those beautiful 70s
monday tuesday
and then we get back to some 60s later
next week
i want to give a big shout out it's
national caregiver day by the way
and there are so many caregivers right
here in southern nevada and around the
world
uh nate i thought i think it was rosalyn
carter who said there are only four
kinds of people in the world
for people who are caregivers people
have been caregivers
people who will be a caregiver or
someone who will need a caregiver who
has received the care yeah